Hey Sebastian,
how's it going?
Hey,
yes.
Good.
Can I ask you 67 questions?
Sure.
Or whatever.
Okay.
What's the culture like at you?
Udacity in one word.
A fearlessness will online learning,
replaced physical learning,
augment it and make it more accessible.
What's something you miss about where you grew up?
Um,
I would love to have grown up in silicon valley,
but people are just crazy.
What time do you wake up?
I wake up to be at eight o'clock.
I'll bring my son to school.
What website you absolutely love to spend time on New York Times.
To be honest.
Favorite machine learning paper of 2016 we have one coming out in nature in
about two weeks and I can't spill the beans,
but as machine learning,
if you could meet one person,
who would it be?
Um,
I love to,
uh,
meet avalanche terrain,
but he's dead.
Unfortunately.
They have a car.
A Tesla used to be a full time professor at Stanford.
What was something surprising about that experience?
That I wasn't kicked out because everybody else was smarter than me.
Very nervous thing you've ever done.
Um,
I,
uh,
snowboarding down a cliff.
What is one thing that scares you?
A actually nothing.
Maybe.
Honestly,
I,
I live to be scared and love surprises.
Hey,
brain instrument,
uh,
as a child as follows,
the saxophone of many years.
Sorry.
I hope you feel better.
Yeah.
It stuck to my mind.
Felt what's more interesting?
Physics or neuroscience.
Neuroscience at this point because physics hasn't changed in a long time.
Best present you've ever received?
Um,
a hug is always the best.
The hug from a family off of my son I love is more than anything else.
What is something you do to chill?
I run,
I bike and I ski.
Anything fast motion.
Honestly,
a flat planes too.
What is something surprising about you?
Um,
I recently had an MRI of my brain.
They found this gap up here around here,
but 2.3 centimeters wide.
I think that it's been normally fears located because I don't have fear.
Do you prefer cats or dogs?
Dogs.
How did you come up with the idea for Google x?
Um,
Vivanta to do innovative stuff.
They wanted to do crazy moonshots.
Uh,
so Larry sloganized set together and ask,
what's the best way to do this favor Google x project?
And there's no favorite,
but the one I'm best known for is the self driving car.
What project are you currently working on?
Uh,
my God,
you'd acidy making education globally accessible and democratize it and double
the world's GDP through education.
If you could repeat one experience again,
what would it be?
A boy being a set of captain was very humbling,
to be honest,
and as many good moments and many bad moments.
So I'd love to do it again.
Why you think deep learning has gotten so popular recently?
It is amazing.
I think we've reached the critical scale of data.
Like if you look at,
uh,
red brain,
you can't teach her event super interesting tricks,
but if you make the larger the human brain,
you can do it.
So I think in computer,
we know reached the size of a human brain.
What is your favorite operating system?
Linux,
of course,
I spend way too much time hacking Linux kernels in my life.
What's your favorite movie matrix?
What is your favorite operating system?
Uh,
it is Linux.
Um,
but I ask a question or even before,
do you collect changed?
Yes.
Do you play any sports?
Uh,
I run,
I ski,
I bike and do anything.
It's fast.
Most adventurous thing you've ever done.
A I f I snowboarded and actually broke my back.
We're stumbling over a cliff.
So then a crazy ski drums before when I was young.
What's one source you use to stay up to date in ml?
Um,
I love browsing the web.
I love talking to people.
I go to conferences,
a lot of stuff in the new city space,
programming,
language of choice for machine learning.
Um,
for me it's either python or Matlab.
Matlab,
because I love fast prototyping and I love the nonpayment and python.
But um,
when I go to production code,
I got a c plus plus favorite professor myself.
Not Hard.
Just as what a joke.
My mentor Tom Mitchell and Carnegie Mellon who was a founder of the machine
learning department is just amazing.
W why do you think programming is fine?
It's amazing.
I love it.
I do it for recreational purposes.
I just program a pseudocode problem solver just because I was jet lagged.
It's fun because it's a great mental exercise.
Favorite comfort food.
Oh my God.
I actually make my own food.
I have a little food invention to make.
Great.
The 19 and a half minutes and I love fish.
Name one person you really admire.
Um,
I would say number one would be Larry Page,
the CEO of alphabet.
And I learned so much from him.
What was your first program?
Uh,
I had a pocket calculator called Texas instrument 57.
You should Google it.
It looks like 1980 [inaudible] and it had 50 programming of steps in.
I spend endless time building video games on a pocket calculator.
What texture,
what techs had or do you use a,
usually EMS.
What?
Open source library do you really like?
Um,
boy,
I do a lot of work on Linux of course,
and I love working on,
uh,
Caitlin and the libraries.
Best advice you've ever received.
Boy,
not to take myself too seriously.
Life is suppose to be fun.
Do you spend more time on the internet or real life?
A real life.
And even when the Internet,
for me it's real life because I interact with people and we have people.
Do you have any pets?
Uh,
only fleas.
Just kidding.
No,
not that I know of.
What's something you've learned in the past month?
Um,
I learned something amazing about crowd sourcing our students.
They produce software for the self driving car as so amazingly strong.
I think we should do much more crowd sourcing facility development.
Do you like spicy food?
I do.
If you ran the world,
what is one lie you would enact immediately?
Um,
I would force every kid in their states to spend one year abroad to understand
that there's more than just America.
Is the singularity near van in the middle of it at this very moment.
Who is one person you looked up to when you were in college?
Again,
my,
uh,
my thesis advisor,
Tom Mitchell,
whom I met when I was in college.
It was just me like a god to me and he helped me understand the importance of
not just doing good research but doing impactful research.
What deep learning library do you use the most?
I think tens of sorts the best right now,
but it's a fast moving field.
If you were to start from scratch today,
what is a learning resource you would use to learn machine learning?
Definitely you'd ask no question.
I think honestly it's not perfect,
but have you done me?
I hope I've done really good job making it accessible.
We have a new foundation on a degree on deep learning,
which is very easy to understand.
What is one goal you have in the next 10 years?
Boy,
I have so many of those.
I love learning new things,
so I get bored when I'm good at something.
So right now I'm learning how to do instrument piloting of planes,
but also like to understand better how to make it as study a really,
really amazing company.
Favorite subject in school when you were growing up?
Math,
if you could be a superhero,
who would it be?
Boy,
I feel sorry.
I feel like Spiderman on the depressed days
and displayed to me.
Batman.
What's your spirit animal?
My spirit animal.
Your spirit animal.
Um Oh my God.
Pokemon.
What do you predict comes next after the deep learning hype?
I think machine,
and we would say,
as we've talked for quite a while,
and this is going to be as big of evolution as the agricultural revolution is
going to come in many shapes.
But,
um,
if I were to add one new thing,
I think we're going to bid machines.
They can browse all the dictionary and the ward or the books in the world and
learn from it.
And combined image based learning and,
and,
and database learning with book learning,
coffee or tea or coffee,
summer or winter.
Uh,
both Google home or Amazon.
Alexa,
definitely Amazon Alexa because it has a name and it's,
you can,
it can,
I can call it my name chrome or safari chrome.
WWDC or Google io deaf and the legal Glioma,
Forensic Bula.
Amazing.
Awesome.
All right,
Sebastian,
thanks so much for answering those questions.